do a lot of projects get Hands-On with
whatever technology you like so funny
story
total comp for this year is between like
140 and 150. last week I flew 20 hours
from Sydney to Seattle to visit the
Amazon headquarters and I asked Amazon
employees how they got into Tech and
what advice they have let's get into it
what is your name your role and how long
have you been at Amazon my name is
Chelsea I'm a specialist Solutions
architect and I've been with Amazon for
one year and six months my name is
Brandon and I am a product marketing
manager at Amazon my name is Eddie Choi
I'm an associate account executive and
I've been at Amazon web services for two
years now my name is lakshia and I'm a
Solutions architect I've been in this
role for one year two months
I started as an intern here uh in July
21 and what I did was I didn't know what
role I was applying to but I wanted
something that wasn't related to
programming but still had technology in
it somehow so I looked at Cloud roles
and one of my friends suggested me
there's a Solutions architect internship
that you can apply for so that's how I
got to know about it I applied and I got
the interview previously I was a
software engineer and I wanted a change
in the role because I was tired of
coding all the time after college I
worked at a startup as a marketing
manager actually and then they sent me
to Vietnam and you know I'm Korean
American and I didn't know the language
and whatnot but I stayed there for a
tiny bit and even though it was a
marketing role essentially I was doing a
lot of sales work and then stumbled into
this job when a recruiter from AWS
reached out to me so I was working in
fashion and I was living in New York and
then one day I got a message in my inbox
for a recruiting for a buying position
at Amazon and that's actually how I was
recruited to come to Seattle I was not
looking for a new job I was not looking
for a new role but I think like the
stars aligned I came out to Seattle to
interview it was pre-pandemic and that's
how I landed my role at Amazon what
advice do you have for people who are
looking to get into Tech more
specifically Amazon do a lot of projects
get Hands-On with whatever technology
you like I started doing that with AWS
as well I didn't know anything when I
started my internship but I started
getting Hands-On I did the certification
the cloud practitioner certification and
the solutions architect associate so
that's how I got my Foundation into
Cloud but if I was in say programming
what I would do is I will find a project
say a web website or it could be a
database project you can choose whatever
you like but get Hands-On and do
something and then add it to your
portfolio my top advice I would say
would be like getting where you fit in
so like I think some people are
sometimes trying to find like the
perfect role the perfect job or like
this like aligns with my resume
perfectly but our organization is really
big
um and there are a lot of opportunities
and you may not come in knowing exactly
what you want to do but if there is
something that you feel is a good fit or
it's something that a recruiter came to
and offered you I would say interview
with it see what the team is like apply
for multiple different roles and not
like your dream role because once you
get in we actually encourage people to
transition and to rotate and to explore
different opportunities which is
something that's very unlike other
companies I've changed teams since I've
been here three times and it's always
been a really positive great experience
would you say you need a technical great
to get into
town so I have a degree in marketing I
have a master's in international
business so non-tech we have a lot of
tech world and a lot of non-tech roles
and you can also join non-tech and then
move into Tech if that's something that
you're interested in um it becomes a lot
easier once you're in the company the 70
roles out there that don't need a
computer science degree and I think
sometimes that's the misconception of
people who want to get into Tech and if
you don't mind sharing what is your
total compensation yeah so comp at
Amazon is a little bit different than a
lot of companies because we are so stock
heavy but my total comp for this year is
between like 140 and 150. according to
levels FYI and Associate Solutions
architect should be making around 130 to
140 and it depends a lot on location
right location years of experience yeah
experience even the domain right that
you are specialized in uh so my role
currently it's in the range from
120k to 150k as associate account
executive so you know it depends also on
your commission and whatnot but you know
it's a that's around the range of the
compensation that's pretty good yeah
what's your favorite part about working
at Amazon I get to learn from other
people around me and I've had the best
mentors I have learned from their
experience and they have given me best
feedback I've ever received to grow my
career as well so as a Solutions
architect I work with early startups in
the west coast and as we all know
startups are very fast paced a few
things that I work with are AIML
blockchain a lot of companies who are in
fintech a lot of times I am looking at
their architecture and telling them
what's good what's not what they could
do in the future what I like the most
about Amazon I think would be the people
like I think we say that a lot but the
bar really is high for like people get
hired here the people who work here what
I love about it is you get to interface
with customers to understand how you can
improve your products better you get to
improve your customers business whether
it's cost wise whether it's operational
wise whether it's sustainability wise so
you know given the current economic
situation what do you think people
should do to upskill and land a job in
Tech use the free trainings available
online YouTube is a great source
everything is out there for free I do
know some people uh would like to start
with the programming language just find
a video that's say four hours or five
hours long that that goes through the
foundations for you and also if you can
go to GitHub find a project that you
like try and read how the the project
was done at least on the non-tech side I
think that you should learn product
skills when you look at demand for for
roles it's a lot of product rule so
those product marketing roles those
product manager roles those are becoming
more and more prevalent you know even if
you're not from a traditional Tech
background right you can go in through
sales for example you can go in through
even friends I know who will do
recruiting back in college I had a lot
of friends who were coders and I thought
that was the only way to get into Tech
right just get your first foot in the
door and you know you can build from
there so for those who are interested in
becoming a Solutions architect what
advice would you have for them so first
you'd be very good at system design you
have to understand how to build a tree
tier web architecture so front-end
back-end database I suggest building
Cloud projects right while attack with
Lucy also be comfortable with not
knowing everything so what we do is we
come with Discovery questions asking the
right questions is also a very important
skill set to have I think a lot of the
role is learning on the job so much of
what I did as an essay I was learning as
I was going you know whether that be
doing certifications working on projects
or even just reading through
documentation before my customer course
hey everyone really hope you enjoyed the
video if you're interested in working at
Amazon and more specifically in a cloud
role I'd highly recommend checking out
these two courses offered by xero to
Mastery the courses help you learn AWS
from the basics all the way to the more
advanced Cloud Concepts it comes with
video lectures Hands-On labs and
practice questions and pretty much
teaches you everything you need to know
to get AWS certified what I love about
xero to Mastery is that once you
purchase a monthly or annual
subscription you can get unlimited
access to all their courses and
workshops they have courses in Python
web development devops and a whole bunch
of other topics all updated for 2023 and
with a focus on teaching you how to
build real world projects rather than
just learning the theory and I think
this is great if you're someone looking
to develop a broad set of technical
skills a lot of their students are now
working at companies like Amazon Google
Apple and meta and by signing up to zero
to Mastery you get access to a community
of over 300 000 other students the
interview questions channel in the
community is an incredible resource when
you're applying to jobs because you can
get your questions answered from people
who have recently gone through the
process so if one of your goals this
year is to land a job in Tech I've
included links in the description below
to five courses from zero to Mastery
that I personally recommend checking out
a big thank you to xero to Mastery for
partnering with me on this video and if
you'd like to see more videos of me
interviewing Amazon employees please let
me know in the comments below awesome
thanks so much Brandon thank you thank
you so much for your time today no
problem thank you